so against my better judgment I decided
over this past weekend to do live
coverage of the Mike Lindell my pillow
Frank speech rally in Wisconsin and I
always love being with you guys love
sharing events with the live audience
but this one was really really tough to
watch it was truly an historic event
organized by Mike Lindell a big Trump
supporter founder and CEO of the my
pillow brand it was a four hour event I
was only able to get through about two
and a half hours before I just had to
bail uh the lineup at this event
included Mike Lindell himself diamond
and silk Charlie Kirk Brandon Howes
Chris Cox Dinesh D'Souza Danielle
D'Souza Sheriff Clark and of course
Donald Trump himself joining the event
via video conference now 99 of what
happened at this event
was merely the disgusting nonsense you
would expect the event had a scheduled
flyover it failed I guess the planes
like didn't show up it was really weird
but it was really capped off by Donald
Trump delivering a deranged and bizarre
speech during which his eyes appeared
almost completely swollen shut we've
seen this with Trump a couple of times
before he was also slurring and seemed
to be engaged in a real battle against
his own tongue uh which was determined
apparently to prevent him from being
able to enunciate anything clearly and
this rally while disgusting and depraved
it really confirmed our suspicions they
seem fully intent on riding this horse
into the 2022 election that's the Trump
horse and they will see how far it gets
them Trump launching right into his
entire I actually won the election thing
the talking points have been the same
for six months and Trump just labored
struggling to speak take a look we went
from 63 million votes and we won to 75
million people and they say we lost but
we didn't lose
75 million votes they say that we lost
now I was told by John McLaughlin who's
considered just about the best pollster
I would say the best pollster there's a
few of them out there towering there are
a few of them out there that are great
sir you got 63 million if you can go up
to 65 you can't lose the election well
you know what happened we went up to 75
and they say we lost the election if you
win Miami if you win Florida if you take
out and win and we won by a lot Florida
and Ohio and then you add Iowa nobody's
ever won those States and lost but we
won those States in Virtual landslides
and they have us losing and there are so
many we held every state house we held
Congress you know it's all so labored
and of course it's the same lies week
after week as you can hear the crowd is
not exactly riveted by by what Donald
Trump is saying here is Donald Trump
delivering a defense of I guess Rudy
Giuliani but it's hard to tell if he
really means it but just not looking
good not sounding good I want to thank
people like Rudy Giuliani who is out
there fighting and they're after him and
they want to take them down they want to
take us all down there's never been a
time like this there's never been it's
weaponized it's weaponized and the
Republicans were very nice our people
were very very nice and very very
respectful and I said this would happen
but Rudy is a great Patriot he was the
greatest mayor in the history of New
York and a great great Patriot and what
he's done and what Mike has done and
what so many other people have done
these are incredible Heroes and they're
going to go down as Heroes someday and I
think it's someday in the not too
distant future so I look forward to
being with you hopefully they go down uh
but not as Heroes hopefully they just go
down for their crimes and misdeeds then
here is Trump really just fighting that
tongue to enunciate coherently saying
China should pay the world for the virus
kind of weird yeah take a look and the
China virus they have to pay reparations
we've been hurt so badly in terms of
death human life and in terms of
monetarily to a level that they have to
pay us and frankly if they paid us 10
trillion dollars that wouldn't cover it
but they really have to pay the world
because this has started in the world
the entire world has been not only
disrupted
um and just the slurring uh the the eyes
uh almost completely shut during this
next segment and then the video froze
which in a sense was like the best
moment of the rant when the video froze
having a hard time with the contractors
I know contractors better than anyone
they're very brilliant they may not read
or write in some cases but you know what
they're smarter than the rest it's more
oh so I just want to thank everybody the
video freezing seemed to get the crowd
more interested than anything Trump had
said up until that point at another
moment Donald Trump falsely claimed to
have stopped the Russian oil pipeline
like it just didn't happen it just
factually untrue did I stopped the
Russia pipeline probably the biggest
pipeline in the world going into Germany
and other countries in Europe it was
stopped never happened just it didn't
happen it's not true a few other really
strange moments here are diamond and
silk apparently explain something about
the so-called audit in Arizona
of the absentee ballots see if you can
understand this question for you okay I
notice how the Democrats is trying to
interfere in a sort of artificial of the
artist
um
I remember them saying that it's an
Insurrection when you try to block the
certification
so my question is if they're trying to
interfere in the artist in Arizona for
example
does that make them an Insurrection
because they try to stop the
verification of the certification of Jim
Crow Joe
good way of looking down
I don't know guys that's pretty strong
I'm I'm pretty convinced I don't know of
what but I'm pretty convinced by that
another favorite moment was when Mike
Lindell claimed that uh I guess a friend
of his had he was banned from Google
Maps
um really weird so a friend of mine
about a month ago
I was on his radio show and they put up
he sent it out the podcast part to all
his Subs he emailed it out 30 000 emails
Google took away his gmails and his
Google Maps I want you to think about
that they took away his Google Maps I
feel like I need an interpreter to even
understand what it is they are claiming
like I I'm having trouble even
adjudicating the claims that are being
made by these people because I don't
even know what the claims are and then
lastly maybe the funniest moment this is
a crowd heading for the exits while Mike
Lindell is speaking apparently the crowd
had had enough
this revival for Jesus in the history of
the world
and but I want to tell you all so I'm
going to tell you what I want to do is I
want to bring it back because how did I
end up here how did we end up here today
especially when I you know here's the
next track addict for Minnesota so I'm
going to tell you a little I'll bring
you back in time you know so if you're
listening today and not watching the
crowd was just heading out while Mike
Lindell was speaking
um this one of my favorite segments from
the Trump era is a segment where Trump
went to India and this big Stadium full
of people started heading towards the
exits as Donald Trump was speaking and
mispronouncing all sorts of Indian names
this was the equivalent this was the
equivalent during the Mike Lindell rally
so another completely humiliating event
but signaling a few things to us number
one the Trump crowd doesn't seem to be
that worried about Sunburn and the
reason I say that is this was a
four-hour event which opened two hours
early and people just sitting in the
blazing hot sun the entire time I I hope
they brought sunscreen but they don't
seem super concerned about sun exposure
that's one thing we learned and number
two they really seem to be on this uh
they're they're not changing horses
Midstream I think would be the the
metaphor that we would apply to this
they seem committed to at least seeing
what trumpianism is going to bring them
through 2022 if it fails then maybe
they'll go a different direction but yet
another complete and total embarrassment
not to be outdone by Marjorie Taylor
green although she's trying let's talk
about that next
one of our sponsors is rise the
science-based app that makes it easy to
improve your sleep and your daily energy
and Rise uses two core principles that
have emerged from sleep science one is
sleep debt as an idea of how much sleep
you owe your body and circadian rhythms
dictating your energy levels and Rise
helps you figure out your sleep needs
helps you track your sleep debt every
morning rise tells you how long you'll
probably be groggy when your high energy
time will be when you should start
winding down for bed to optimize your
sleep and so you can make science-based
improvements to 16 different sleep
habits to improve your daytime energy
I've been using rise myself on my phone
I started noticing higher quality sleep
in a few nights and it's allowed me to
just better understand how my energy
levels correspond with my sleep and I've
had a really great experience with it my
audience can try rise for free for an
entire week by going to rise science.com
Pacman the link is right underneath this
video